Oh
member
boom
Oh
each
so this is the the dancing from Team
bridge and I just like to ask you how
have you found it working outside it's
been different it's different i'll get
it gonna be right you have been raining
a bit fair yeah the readings are the web
hasn't been good but it's been good
tried to like adjust the inside works
doing it outside and doing all
differently from like the rain of issues
made the pool wet so we've had to adjust
our dances yes then it's get experience
or try different things and and you move
now that's right you've had a piece of
um Jim apparatus and to work on which is
just behind you it's it's the low bench
and you learn some dance sequences and
then we asked you to work with their
sequences on the bench and in and around
the site how have you found that it was
a bit difficult at first I kind of like
when she bends where I'll bench what do
we do a bench yes with the vengers work
around the ventures and legs yes and did
you find it useful having some dance
being given some on dance ideas to begin
with to use as a springboard because
that was that useful maybe an idea of
what sure like what you expected I do as
guidelines yeah road and do you think
that you'll go on and do some more
on-site dance now that you've had this
experience yes have you got any ideas of
where you'd like to take dance to any
college at college yeah great around the
college sites i mean there must be loads
of places that you could choose you know
sitting areas feel some new and welcome
anywhere really anywhere absolutely and
that's the the main aim behind dance is
that it can be accessed absolutely
everywhere and anywhere great thank you
very much and well done fabulous work